[Musique]
leur un véritable autoroute fluviale du
nord de l'europe
chaque année ce sont près de 300
millions de tonnes de marchandises qui
suit son cours de la suisse jusqu'au
bord de mer du nord grand port du sud de
l'alsace
les ports de mulhouse-rhin sont
implantés sur trois sites à ottmarsheim
huningue et sur l'île napoléon en 2017
près de 5 millions de tonnes de
marchandises en vrac et en conteneurs
ont transité sur ses quais mais qu'on ne
s'y trompe pas un port aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas que des quais des grues et de
la manutention
on y fait en fait bien plus que chargé
et déchargé des pays
c'est véritablement un carrefour on est
devenu ce qu'on appelle communément des
spécialistes de la rupture de charge et
donc c'est chez nous que vont se faire
le passage d'un mode de transport à un
autre on retrouve sur un site unique la
partie fluviale donc avec des arrivages
ou des départs donc bateau on retrouve
la partie ferroviaire qui ont la
particularité ces deux premiers modes
des thèmes des maudits massifier donc on
va avoir des grosses quantités de
marchandises des gros volumes et ensuite
on va retrouver la partie logistique qui
devient de plus en plus importante
puisqu'il faut à un moment donné ouvrir
les contenait retraités les conteneurs
etc et bien entendu la partie camions
qui reste le seul vecteur je dirais de
flux qui permettent de partir de la cour
du fournisseur et pour aller jusque dans
la cour du client une zone portuaire
comme celle d'ottmarsheim représente un
véritable intérêt pour les entreprises
qui s'installent à proximité
ces dernières peuvent y trouver
l'ensemble des solutions logistiques
nécessaires à leur activité que ce soit
pour recevoir des matières premières ou
expédier des produits finis pour le porc
ces entreprises voisines c'est aussi
l'assurance d'avoir du trafic
c'est pour cela que les ports de
mulhouse-rhin dispose de terrains pour
que vienne s'y implanter de nouvelles
sociétés
aujourd'hui nous avons à disposition
environ cent cinquante 150 hectares de
terrain et là l'objectif c'est d'amener
des instincts des industriels à
s'implanter en zone portuaire pour
profiter du port comme instrument de
développement et un comme outil mais
aussi pour alimenter le port d'un autre
côté la particularité des ports c'est
que c'est une entreprise de services de
report modal au profit des entreprises
et tout l'intérêt pour les porcs c'est
d'avoir non seulement une activité
portuaire de manutention mais aussi une
gestion de foncier qui très importante
pour permettre le développement des
activités
on parle beaucoup quand on parle de porc
d'hinterland l'hinterland c'est la zone
d'attractivité ou de chalandise qui
intéresse les ports pour nous d'avoir
120 hectares de foncier disponible à
côté des ports c'est quelque chose qui
permet d'accueillir de l'entreprise en
liaison avec les ports bien entendu et
d'être très fortement moteur pour
l'ensemble du sud alsace
entreprise rentable employant près d'une
centaine de personnes les ports de
mulhouse-rhin sont un fleuron industriel
pour le sud du département
mais c'est aussi et surtout un atout
dans la compétition pour conserver et
attirer de nouvelles industries ainsi le
développement du port accompagne le
développement tétouan où il est implanté
ce port c'est un point important pour
notre territoire parce que juste de
l'autre côté à droite
à ma droite s'ils voulaient se trouve là
tout toutes les industries de la bande
rhénane dont des grosses pointures comme
solvay boréalis buta chimie et j'en
passe et puis à ma gauche se trouve
effectivement le territoire allemand qui
n'est qu'à 4 kilomètres 6 2
d'ottmarsheim si le rhin marque la
frontière entre l'allemagne et la france
dans le sud de l'alsace cette limite
tend à s'effacer dans de nombreux
domaines on regarde par delà leurs seins
chez nos voisins suisses et allemands
c'est bien sûr le cas pour les ports de
mulhouse où ici plus qu'ailleurs les
échanges à l'échelle de l'europe sont au
coeur du métier
si vous tracez avec un compas un rayon
de 50 à 60 kilomètres autour de nos
ports vous retrouverez immanquablement
nos amis suisses
nos amis allemands donc on a un vrai
besoin est de travailler ensemble au
même titre qu'on a su le faire à l'epo
pour l'aéroport de bâle mulhouse
ben il faut qu'on essaye de le faire
également pour les porcs il ya
effectivement une stratégie de
partenariat les ports de mulhouse-rhin
sont aujourd'hui le troisième port
fluvial français
quand on est sur la plateforme de
huningue on regarde à droite on voit le
port de bâle on regarde en face on voit
le port de vannes amrhein et nous avons
créé entre le port de bahreïn le port de
bâle et les ports de mulhouse-rhin une
structure qui s'appellera une porte qui
a déjà mené un certain nombre de projets
qui est également une vitrine pour art
voire plus d'attrait visiter cyrène
porte était un port à part entière bien
intégré il serait le deuxième port
européen français dans la matière en
matière fluvial donc c'est quelque chose
qui donne de la visibilité qu'on met en
avant quand nous sommes dans des salons
pour dire bah c'est pas seulement des
ports de mulhouse-rhin côté français il
y à aussi la sortie verbale et la sortie
vers l'allemagne et tout cela
cette collaboration nous a permis aussi
de créer des logiciels notamment pour
lui disais l'ensemble du trafic sur
l'ensemble du rhin et à destination de
nos ports mais travailler avec des
voisins de langue germanique sur des
projets à l'échelle européenne nécessite
un environnement favorable que le
conseil départemental construite
patiemment notamment dans le domaine de
la pratique des langues
le côté transfrontalier c'est une
réalité parce qu'en développe et on a
certainement développer beaucoup plus
tôt que d'autres le ce qu'on appelle le
linguiste ou alors aujourd'hui le
multilinguisme alors c'est un atout
effectivement de parler plusieurs
langues parce qu'il peut effectivement
ou bosser ici ou bosser aussi également
en allemagne en suisse et proposer un
albanais en suisse pour parler
l'allemand si possible et aujourd'hui
même je dirais il faut également parler
l'anglais une façon d'inscrire le
territoire dans le dynamisme de l'espace
rhénan
du côté du port on regarde en tout cas
l'avenir de façon positive
un opérateur privé devrait rentrer au
capital du port d'ici 2020 aux côtés de
la cci de vnf d agglomération de
mulhouse et saint louis ainsi que de la
région
un partenariat public privé qui devrait
assurer le développement
les années à venir